that's right well like you and denise
mentioned new covet 19
data shows clark county is the worst in
the country
for positive cases and deaths now take a
look on your screen you can see a map
there where clark county is one of a few
around the country colored in dark
showing a critical status compared to
other counties and states
now this is according to a cdc report
released yesterday where more than 1.5
million new cases were reported
nationwide and more than 18
600 deaths were reported in the last
seven days now today local health and
state leaders
say there is a high demand for the
public for the vaccine
and a very slow delivery from the
government's operation warp speed
the federal government is is holding
back that second dose and
essentially they're doing that for every
single jurisdiction and state
well the biggest problem they face is
predicting a timeline because the
shipments of vaccines are being
delivered differently each week
sometimes
it's not even what was ordered as the
state wraps up tier 1 the next phase
includes a larger number of people which
they claim will be a challenge in terms
of storage thawing plan
and how many doses local partners can
get through
a week now they also added that the data
from christmas and new year's
is still coming in they keep asking for
patience from the public in the newsroom
christian casadas 8 news now